the airline industry is struggling with
the backlash from a string of
confrontations with passengers one of
the latest involves a family that
accused JetBlue over the weekend of
kicking them off of a flight they had
stored a birthday cake in an overhead
been reserved for safety equipment the
low-cost airline says in a statement the
customers were agitated cursed and
yelled at the crew and made false
accusations about crew members fitness
to fly the family claims that they were
not competitive JetBlue president and
CEO Robin Hayes is here for an interview
that you will see only on CBS this
morning good morning to you miss days
and welcome back good morning it's great
to be back is it great to be back great
to be back you would schedule this
interview before this incident so I can
I I did we're thinking I did oh great
I'm still going on CBS this morning
we thank you very much for coming but
let's start with the cake and then go on
with other things you know the family
says look we did what we were told are
you here as an airline CEO as others
have been in the past to apologize for
the actions of your crew look we we fly
38 million customers a year so
thankfully these events are very rare
what happened here was a customer stored
two items one was a cake another was a
bag in a party airplane reserved for
safety equipment and we trained our crew
that those lockers have to be kept only
for safety equipment and the the family
concerned ignored repeated requests to
move it out crew even moved it at one
point for them and they moved it back
and then they said some very they made
some sort of allegations that gates the
crew and it got to a point where the
captain felt you know balancing the
interests of all the other customers on
the airplane and the crew the right
thing to do was ask that family to leave
the airplane society it is where but the
the crew number one value at safety is
JetBlue we have to have access to those
lockers and our crew need to when that
door shut and that planes in the air for
five hours to Vegas we need to know that
everyone's going to work with your job
to make an exception to the but people
still say listen it was a birthday cake
what it was it was not about the
birthday cake it was it was about the
the need to could work together you know
when when we will fly and when that
airplane is door shot and the crew
the crew have to maintain a great
environment on board for all of our
customers what are the rules of
engagement between crew and passengers
when you want to remove them and they're
reluctant to go well what what what we
do is that if the if the customer after
many attempts to get follow the
instructions refuses to do it then and
they then refuse to remove themselves in
the aircraft we will ask everyone to
come off the aircraft and we will
rebuild the air plot aircraft with the
other customers and that's indeed what
happened here I mean now that these
confrontations they're actually not more
common they're just more reported
because I was using their cell phones to
share the video what does JetBlue doing
and what does an airline company do look
let's let's be honest flying is very
stressful I mean when when how that
airline was founded it was founded with
a mission to inspire humanity you know
we're very proud of the customer service
that our crew members provide we think
that is a point of differentiation for
JetBlue you know we offer the most
legroom in in the cabin because that's
important we offer free TV we offer free
Wi-Fi we offer free drinks and snacks we
don't oversell our flight so I think at
JetBlue we're doing our bit but at the
end of the day you know I think civility
is important and when you're in an
aluminium chew for a few hours and we've
got new neighbors if we couldn't all
this just be nice to each other I think
it's just going to make the flight your
bed affect its ability on both sides
exactly exactly
aluminium to bazoo is a British
expression it is it is I'm sorry roughly
80% of the airline market is now
controlled by large airlines not
including JetBlue what impact do you
think this has on consumers does this
mean we're paying more for flights than
we should be it's something we're very
concerned about at JetBlue because we've
seen a lot of consolidation in the u.s.
we now have four large airlines with
over 80% and it's meaning it means for
airlines like JetBlue getting into new
markets sometimes can be very
challenging when we come into a market
we love affairs I mean we started flying
a Boston LaGuardia recently fares came
down by up to 70%
we just started flies to Atlanta
that is an airport with 193 gates and we
were told we we only could get one and
we had to share it and and so it's a
real challenge and I think the issue of
access and the issue of making sure
small smaller pro-competitive Pro
customer airlines like JetBlue have
access to these congested airports is
something that we need to have a
national conversation on prices go up
and down as oil prices go up and down in
the past that's that's been the case to
to a large degree but I think now what
we what I'm concerned about going
forward with the power in the hands of
so few airlines that those airlines have
a lot ability to kind of control the
pricing environment and I don't think
that's good for customers longer term
everybody wants better service in lower
prices but then come to JetBlue and
we'll do our bit they'll want more mint
mint girl they're looking for we have
our new la term ripening up on Thursday
and we hope to see you through there guy
terrific white party or in LAX we're
moving to Terminal five hold the welcome
Gill king terms it is I think we may
need a new and four here for the ribbon
cutter thank you so much thank you for
honoring your commitment to come Oh
always happy to be here thank you so
much thank you